We now have some context around how the location of
a World Cup affected its attendance, but since we overlaid circles for
all the years at once, the context of time has gotten lost.
Or rather, we have sacrificed time for space, or geography in this case.
As we saw with our previous plots and charts, there's quite a big dependence of
the total attendance of a World Cup with the year it was held, with the trend
being as time went on, World Cup attendance has steadily increased.
One way to get the best of both worlds, geography and
time, is to leverage animation to encode the passage of time.
Remember previously that we mentioned animation can be thought of something
of another visual encoding that helps convey the change of some data over time.
I wanted to take a step back also so
that we can remember where we are in the process.
We will be creating a drill down story following the martini glass narrative
structure, but
currently we only have a static map that represents the base of our glass.
While this is a great foundation and starting point for
what we will be building, we still need to construct the stem of our glass,
as well as the mouth of our glass.
We will now begin building up the stem of our glass,
through an author driven narrative with animation.
And we will finish the mouth of our glass,
with a reader driven narrative, enabled through interaction, and
remember, we're at our starting point with our base map.
We'll be narrowly guiding the reader with our author driven narrative, and
then allow them to open up and
explore their own narrative through interaction in the mouth of the glass